this is a detailed video on quantitative
realtime PCR stay tuned till the end and
you would learn many things about
quantitative
PCR quantitative real-time PCR is used
in research and Diagnostics to detect
and quantify specific RNA molecules in
the time of coid quantitative realtime
PCR became really popular and every one
of us has some idea about qpcrs or rtpcr
so it has biomedical applications and it
has applications in clinical
diagnosis so let's talk about the qpcr
applications in a nutshell so qpcr is
used to quantitative analysis of the
gene expression viral load pathogen
detection genetic testing or even
plasmid copy number
detection now viral load detection and
its example was very evident during the
time of coid literally every everyone
was undergoing a qpcr reaction right to
detect specific
viral viral DNA from their
samples alongside viral load detection
there could be gene expression analysis
that is very evident for the scientist
in biomedical Labs also qpcr can be
combined with other techniques like
chromatin imuno precipitation to analyze
the transcriptor transcription Factor
binding to a specific DNA segment so all
these applications make qpcr a valuable
technique for biologist that's why we
should learn the technical details of
quantitative
PCR so question is how to set up a
quantitative PCR and it's not really
difficult to set up a quantitative PCR
in the lab so let's learn the process
these are the reagents required
obviously we can we need to have DNA or
cdna in this example it's
cdna then appropriate primers forward
and reverse primers
dntps cyber green mixture and polymerase
mix so basically cyber green is helping
in the detection process and polymerase
would help in the PCR reaction so this
particular video talks about the Cyber
green chemistry but there are other tman
based assays which can also be used for
quantitative PCR but the most used say
is cyber green that's why we are talking
about cyber green as well then the
assembling all the reaction mixture is
done in a tube or in a 96 well plate and
it is loaded in the qpcr machine which
reads these
plate so what really happens inside the
tube each of these machine has specific
detectors for fluorescence so now let us
look at one particular reaction and the
Cyber green chemistry so this this is a
DNA and cyber green is a Dye which is uh
present in the solution and when it is
in the solution and in in its Unbound
format it doesn't flues but when it
binds to the double stranded DNA it can
flues and that is what is detected in
quantitative realtime PCR so imagine
this is the cycle number one in the PCR
and you have to simplify things and
understand okay we are only starting
with one DNA but it doesn't happen in
reality there are obviously more and
more number of dnas to start with but in
our linear example imagine we are
starting with one DNA in the cycle
number one so what happens in the cycle
number
two so there would be two copies of DNA
right and obviously there would be a
little bit more fluoresence compared to
the first cycle think about cycle number
three and cycle number four gradually
the fluoresence levels are increasing
because more and more DNA molecules are
produced so obviously there are more die
binding to the DNA molecules now let us
look at this conceptuality in a
graphical format so the machine displays
this data as a relative fluoresence unit
in the y- AIS and cycle number on the
x-axis so what happens in the initial
cycle the fluoresence level doesn't grow
that much but after a point florescent
level grows and Crosses a detection
threshold
and after that the reaction moves like a
uh exponential curve so at a particular
cycle number where the
fluoresence uh reaches the threshold is
known as the cycle threshold CT or CQ
I'm sure that in coid you already heard
about the CT or CQ
values so let's see why this is
important so CT value gives idea about
relative
abundance so this is the dete ction
threshold imagine this particular red
curve is corresponding to a gene a and
blue curve corresponding to Gene B so
from the CT value can you imagine which
one has a higher
abundance okay now if you understand it
properly the abundance is high for the
red Gene because its CT value is low
that means it takes less amount of
Cycles to reach the detection threshold
if the is high there would be already
more DNA to start with so it the
threshold Crossing is
quicker
so basically the blue curve took more
time to cross the threshold and now we
are going to look at exactly the
programs in the machine and how exactly
that means so this is how a typical
qpcr uh qpcr program look like in a qpcr
machine so in this case you can see at
95° integrate what happens the DNA
strand separates that is the
denaturation step which is true for any
PCR reaction then in the analing step
the primers anal to the specific region
dedicated for them to bind and the main
thing happens in the step number four in
this case so the extension while
extending cyber green di also binding
and that is the step where the machine
detects the
fluoresence after the reaction is over a
melt curve analysis is performed and in
a moment it would be clear why melt
curve is important so imagine we have we
have a qpcr graph like this and this we
have done this for 30th cycle so of the
30th cycle the reaction kind of reached
the plateau so we have this amount of uh
DNA to start with then after that what
happens gradually the temperature is
increased in a 1° increment scale so
this is called a melt curve melt curve
uh kind of cycle so in this case what
happens if we increase the temperature
after a Time Point these products which
are formed in PCR would melt down their
DNA strands would separate and exactly
at a particular temperature when the
milk when the DNA strands separate we
don't see fluoresence because the Cyber
green then moves out and in Unbound
State cyber green doesn't fluorescent so
there would be a dramatic drop in the
fluoresence that could be found in this
curve
so this is exactly known as the melting
temperature now this is a graphical
representation of the data that the
machine spits out so here you can see
there are three important type of curves
so one one is the amplification curve
that tells us whether amplification
happened or not so you can see here
there are two examples in this case in
the left side you can see the cycle
threshold is around 20 and on the right
side you can see the cycle threshold is
around 30 so the Cycles are basically on
the x-axis so obviously you can
understand which Gene is more abundant
or less abundant then you can look at
the Melt curve so you can see at a
particular two of these genes doesn't
have a similar melt curve the gene on
the right hand side melts at 85°
temperature look at the x-axis and in
the left hand side you can see that
melting temperature is somewhere between
78 or 76 something like
that and obviously this melt
uh curves can be visualized as a
derivative the change in fluoresence
over time so that gives us this kind of
melt Peaks but question is what what is
the importance of these kind of Peaks it
turns out melt individual melt picks
tells you that okay there is only one
amplicon so that is really important to
do at the end of qpcr it ensures that
your amplification is specific and not
halfhazard
so let's talk about the qpcr data
analysis it can be done by several
method one of the most popular method is
relative quantification by leac methods
also known as Delta Delta City method so
imagine these are the city values for
Gene X that we want to detect from our
sample and these are the housekeeping
reference in this case it is 18s
ribosomal RNA is the housekeeping so
first we calculate the Delta C Delta CT
simply means the CT values for every any
Gene minus the CT value of 18s here note
that on the uh uh left side there are
samples from control and a mutant
situation as well so for each of these
samples the CT Delta CT values would be
calculated after
that the the average CT values can be uh
determined basically control 1 and
control 1 simply means there are two
technical replicates that means control
one two samples are not really
biologically different they are exactly
technically uh different so they are
loaded two times just to have a uh kind
of like a technical validation so that
is why we average them eventually there
is a calibrator that means uh the all
the uh average of all the control
samples so here the control 1 control 2
and control 3 Delta cities would be
averaged as a calibrator then we will be
having something called Delta Delta CT
that means CT values minus the Delta CT
values minus the calibrator values and
you can see Delta Delta city is like
that and finally the fold change would
be calculated as 2 the^ minus Delta
Delta City and this is uh properly known
as leac method the paper link is
provided in the description here you can
see how the fold chain look like one can
definitely plot it in a graph and from
the graph you can see the control CT
values or control fold change basically
Falls near the range one so you can see
the overall average is near one
so with respect to control you can see
there is a down regulation of that
particular Gene X in the mutant scenario
so this obviously gives us an idea about
gene expression changes and which is
super important for any um academician
or a clinician in this
case and you can also perform statistics
like student te test and man Whitney
test all of these to understand whether
there is a significant difference or
not now let us get back to the Melt
curve amplification curve and melt curve
so here you can see this is the
amplification curve and this is the Melt
curve or melt Peak analysis so here you
can see there is this is the negative
control which has a CT value far away
from the uh normal any normal gen normal
genes and whose melt Peaks are also
shifted from the main cohort so this is
something to check from your reaction so
this is an example where the
amplification curves looks okay but look
at the Melt Peak so basically you can
see there are many peaks in the Melt
Peak that simply
means this is not a proper reaction so
this kind of multiple Peaks means there
are non-specific amplification once you
get these kind of data simply you have
to optimize your
primers so one this this melt Peck one
and two simply means there are multiple
products maybe one is corresponding to
your non-space specific amplification
one is your desired product so in this
case one can use a technique called
gradient PCR to optimize their primer in
the gradient PCR using different uh
gradient thermal block one can basically
uh understand which particular
temperature is optimal for a primer
hybridization so instead of one
particular uh primer analing step there
are multiple uh temperatures which are
assigned to the primary and Link step
and it is done with a specific
thermocouple present in the PCR machine
later on one can run it on a gel to
understand which is the desired
temperature which give us best band for
example in this case you can see 62.3 is
a good particular temperature which give
us a band and doesn't have other
non-specific bands and it has a desired
and significant yield you can see 49 or
50 has given several different bands due
to non-specific
amplification so that is why this is how
one can optimize the prime and do their
qpcr in a more efficient way so
obviously what determines the success of
a qpcr reaction these are optimal
reaction conditions primer designing
amplification efficiency quality of the
RNA and cdna and pipeting efficiency all
these factors matter for a successful
qpcr experiment so I hope this was very
useful if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe please share this
video with your friends if you think it
is useful share with your friends
support our Channel using super thanks
and see you in next
video